hey guys this is Pete peppers this is a
candy crush jelly saga how-to for what I
think is the toughest new game-mode or
level type in the game the cupcake Carl
game mode and it involves popplers if
you haven't watched our popplers video
to check that out to learn more about
them but I'm just gonna concentrate on
how we have to go up against Carl
himself so Carl is like the Queen which
again if you haven't watched our how to
beat the Queen video yet you should
probably check that out but when we play
against the Queen we have to spread jam
more than her cover her color up right
so with cupcake Carl here we have to
actually catch more muffler's than he
does so you can see that you catch
poplars just like you would on any other
level but the one thing to notice here
is we have a meter and we have a total
of three that we need to get before he
gets a total of three okay so it doesn't
necessarily mean that they're 6-under
here I think it actually might mean that
there's a few more but the first first
player either us or Carl who gets to 3
wins the level so the biggest standout
in this versus mode compared to the
Queen is since we're removing ice and
he's doing the same thing you know we
have to actually plan out so that we
don't leave a situation where he can you
know we knock all the ice except for one
square off and then he can just come in
and take our our spoils or whatever you
want to say so just like any versus
level you know you can see I got a
triple stun so that's always a good
thing to do you see the sparkling on the
outside I made you know as many specials
as I could to know like say here
I could I could match these two together
if I don't he might but say here since I
have the the super match or whatever
they call it I should be able to free
this entire poplar here just like that
so if you get your you know your super
match probably a good idea to do that
since we're you know we're competing so
now I'll just continue to look for more
specials I can make and or you know
where I can get this guy out over here
neither one of them looks real good
see if I pop the top off of here
then that'll he'll probably move but
just really not an advantage it's really
just gonna get that ready for Carl so
you could play defense here you know 11
moves left
you know yeah I'm just gonna go ahead
and do that just move remove a useless
piece of ice and sort of wait to see
what what materializes so here I can
make a fish or I can make a wrapped and
I'm gonna get an extra move go ahead and
make the wrap and move down as you saw
but I can free this one up here so you
know this is a tip of the whole decision
that you'll come across when you're
playing and since we have to get the
thing we're going to get that first but
you know making this match would would
open up a little bit of the space but it
doesn't make it special so it doesn't
stun Carl and he gets to move next so
you definitely want to go for free and
popular that you can see right there
rather than you know any other kind of
move that would take you away from
taking the lead so here we have one
there may be enough there may be two
here actually there are two here so the
main thing we want to do is not let him
get to before we get one more
so mmm
none of these moves are that great I'm
just gonna go ahead and drop this to
change things up a little bit that's
gonna
pretty good go to makeup special
but luckily he's not that smart and he
decided to do that I can make this big
and collect the last one at the same
time and that's pretty much how it works
so this is the simplest of all the
cupcake Carl levels these get really
tough later on crush so some general
tips you want to keep in mind are like
just what try to anticipate what he's
going to be and there's a lot of
frustration with that more so than the
Queen because the Queen not being good
at making you know like moves where they
have it you know like where they're
planning for their next move is it's
helpful because you're just spreading
jam but with Carl sometimes it's hard to
anticipate what you know it's hard to
set up something in the future because
even though you know the to a human
opponent it might be a really obvious
thing that he should do he's gonna still
pick like the simplest one so he can
kind of like you know at least for me
he's frustrated me on on several
different situations where I was just
like how would he you know real person
would never make that move or whatever
so it can be it can be tough but um as
long as you're sore thinking ahead you
know you're gonna play better than he
does but you know just kind of kind of
try to take into it into account like
what you might do based on his level of
play if that makes sense and you know
don't try to overthink it too much if
you get if you end up getting beat by
him a couple times I'd rather just hang
in there check out one of us check out
our video of how we did it and most of
the time you'll be able to beat him
before too long so I don't want to
stretch this into a really long video
I'll go ahead and cut it off if you got
any questions about Carl or any of the
other game modes you know leave a
question in the comments
hopefully you'll like this video if you
found it helpful and you'll subscribe to
my channel you know we make the best
how-to commentary videos and we keep up
to date with a lot of popular games so
that you can get your level of videos as
soon as they are released so definitely
subscribe so you can keep up to date
with things and I'll see you soon